There are so many new beauty products
being released all the time,
so we gathered some of the most hyped
to test for ourselves.
First up, we have the L'Oréal Fresh Wear
Foundation in a Powder.
I have zero experience
with powder foundations,
so this one made me nervous.
This stuff is full coverage.
Like, covered all of my dark
spots and acne, no problem.
The application was surprisingly smooth
and I didn't notice any dry patches,
and all of my other products
layered so well over it.
Here's what it looked
like eight hours later.
I did get oily,
but I still feel like the
foundation looks beautiful.
The EcoTools BioBlender Makeup Sponge
is a 100% biodegradable makeup sponge,
which is so exciting!
This sponge blends really, really well.
It's a bit firmer in
texture, but I didn't mind.
And the shape lets you get into
those hard-to-blend areas.
It's recommended that you
compost it after 30 days,
which at 5 bucks a sponge isn't terrible.
It also comes in 100% plantable packaging,
which is such a cool touch.
The Sally Hansen Hydrate Peel-Off
Nail Mask Treatment is like a little tiny
peel-off mask for each of your nails.
It's meant to relieve
dry nails and cuticles.
You just apply a layer to each nail
and peel off after 15 minutes.
I definitely did too thick
of a layer on my nails,
so it didn't peel perfectly,
but my nails and cuticles
felt nice afterwards.
It does feel like a
gimmicky sort of product,
but still fun to use.
I finally got my hands
on the ABH Brow Freeze,
and there is a reason why
this stuff is sold out everywhere.
This stuff is amazing.
It definitely gives your brows
that laminated, fluffy look
with little to no effort.
This is what it looks like
on my brows with no makeup,
I just wanted to see how it made them look
without filling them in,
and they look so full.
It also has serious staying power.
Here's what my brows looked
like at the end of the day,
and there's not a hair out of place.
The Ordinary Concealer
claims to be full coverage,
but I feel like it's more medium.
You could probably build
this up if you wanted to.
I definitely got the wrong shade
because my skin hasn't
seen the sun in ages,
but I'm not super in love with this.
I feel like my dark under eyes
weren't super covered,
and I hate this sort of
packaging for concealers.
I just feel like I've
tried better concealers
at this $5 price point.
But one great thing is that it does have
a diverse range of shades and undertones.
I was so excited to try out
the Milk Makeup Color Chalk
because Milk is one of my favorite brands,
but I think this one is a miss.
It's definitely...a chalk.
It's pretty dry,
and it needs some
moisture to spread easier,
so I used my setting spray to help.
I feel like I had to apply a lot
to get the payoff that I wanted,
which normally wouldn't bother me,
but this thing is so
tiny it's unbelievable.
Like, this tiny thing costs $18.
The packaging is also kind of messy,
but it is refillable, which I like.
And I actually ended up loving
this coppery orange color.